[Music]
scp-3935 is an extra dimensional
anomalous space located beneath
Salvation High School in Salvation
Indiana the whole town has been affected
by the anomaly causing strange
occurrences both within the high school
and its vicinity
scp-3935's anomalous nature was
discovered in 1976 following paranormal
activities at the school the discovery
was made when a custodial staff member
found a gap in a collapsed wall that led
to scp-3935 a member of an audit team
accidentally falling into the Gap did
not return prompting a search by the
contractor team and local authorities
the town of Salvation has since been
evacuated and cordoned off with a
quarantine Zone established around it
due to the escalating anomalous activity
outside the high school no explorations
of scp-3935 are allowed and people
suspected of being affected by it are to
be evaluated at a nearby temporary site
furthermore it is believed that the
original inhabitants of Salvation are
unable to reproduce any deviation from
this is to be closely monitored